[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture I
introduced the discrete Fourier
transform which is a matrix transform
that takes you from a vector of data
sampled at regular intervals in space or
time
to a vector of Fourier coefficients of
complex Fourier coefficients for that
data okay so this is the discrete
analogue of the Fourier series which
would approximate this this function
using sines and cosines of higher and
higher frequency the discrete Fourier
transform approximates this data using
sines and cosines with discrete
frequencies that are increasing from
from from 0 to n minus 1 okay so we
derived this discrete Fourier transform
matrix in terms of this fundamental
frequency Omega n where Omega n was e to
the minus 2 pi I over N ok that's kind
of the the fundamental frequency that
you can get on this interval with n data
points ok and now what I'm going to show
you is how to compute this DFT matrix in
MATLAB and in Python so just huge
caution you almost never actually want
to compute the discrete Fourier
transform matrix you always compute the
discrete Fourier transform using the
fast Fourier transform algorithm pretty
much always I'm just showing you this
because it looks cool and because I
wanted to show you how you would
actually build this if for some reason
you wanted to okay now some things to
point out this discrete Fourier
transform matrix has some really
important properties this is what's
known as a vandermonde matrix it is also
a unitary matrix so just like in the
singular value decomposition we saw that
unitary matrices were really important
this is kind of the original really
important unitary matrix is the discrete
Fourier transform and unitary again
means that if you have two high
dimensional vectors that have given
inner product in in real space when I
map them through into this discrete
Fourier transform coordinate system I
still have the same
product okay so it preserves angles and
distances through this map very
important property that's what allows us
to approximate data using these Fourier
transforms efficiently okay so we're
gonna see a lot more about this later
but here I'm just going to show you how
to code this up in MATLAB and Python
it's really simple in pink here you can
see this is kind of the slow kind of
easy way to compute it would be with two
for loops you just go through I and
through J to compute these these
coefficients just like I've done here in
terms of this fundamental frequency W or
Omega this is a better way of computing
this more efficiently or faster where
you basically create a grid an N by n
array of IJ locations and then you
compute Omega to all of those indexes
all at once using this dot ^ I minus 1
times J minus 1 okay so what this is is
I and J are both big arrays of every I
and J index over this whole array and
you can simultaneously take W to all of
those powers at once in this vectorized
operation in MATLAB so vectorized
operations are always much much faster
so this is kind of the easy human
readable code this is how you would
actually compute it fast in MATLAB and
now I'm gonna show you just the real
part of this DFT matrix so remember this
is a complex valued matrix because these
Fourier coefficients have a magnitude
and a phase they don't just tell you how
much of that sine or cosine it tells you
what's the phase so of course you know I
have maybe my fundamental frequency the
magnitude tells you how big to scale it
but the phase tells you if it should be
shifted to one side or to the other so
the phase and the magnitude are both
important and they're both captured by
this complex Fourier coefficient and so
I'm just gonna plot you the real part of
this this DFT matrix okay good that's
right here and so I'm gonna make this
much bigger
so this is what my discrete for you
transform matrix looks like okay you can
see kind of there's a lot of interesting
patterns here there's bands of like you
know positive negative positive negative
or like big small a lot of really
interesting structure in this 1024 by
1024 matrix one of the things I think is
kind of fun is that if you change the
size of this when you're looking at it
on a computer screen when you're looking
at this on a computer screen then then
you'll get some interesting aliasing
effects so here I'm just gonna slowly
vary the size of this thing and you're
gonna see notice that the cells it
almost looks like there are cells
forming and as I change the size of this
thing you can see kind of this
interesting aliasing pattern let me see
if I can get a really good one yeah okay
it's about to happen yes you can see all
these really interesting patterns now it
looks like there's three cells in the
vertical direction here I can probably
make it more or less anyway this is
essentially because there's only so many
pixels on the screen and this is exactly
1024 by 1024 matrix and so yeah if you
make it smaller it's actually really
cool so essentially if I try to
represent this 1024 by 1024 matrix on a
smaller number of pixels then there's
some aliasing and this just points to
the fact that there is so much symmetry
and structure in this Fourier transform
matrix because you know each row is very
similar to the previous row it's kind of
off by a factor of Omega and there's all
of this this structure in this matrix
and you can kind of see lots of
interesting structure here okay now this
is really easy to compute in Python as
well and it's pretty much exactly the
same you create a mesh grid you can
pre-compute a power and here again we're
plotting the real part of this discrete
Fourier transform matrix okay
now I'll just point out that in real
life you're almost never going to
actually compute this DFT matrix that's
not how you're actually gonna Fourier
transform data you're going to use the
fast Fourier transform algorithm
I just thought it was cool to show you
kind of what this matrix looks like okay
so in the next few lectures we're gonna
walk through how to compute the fast
Fourier transform where it comes from
why it's useful and how you can use it
to compute the Fourier transform of data
vectors even if they're very very large
like like high-resolution images or
audio signals things like that okay
thank you